so what you're claiming is guess what I
don't care about what he's what the
court documents say I don't care what
the witness is saying but guess what in
the video he said this and therefore he
should be convicted or based on the
video no there's only two explanations
for the video because the court
documents don't add up to what the video
says either he was exaggerating and
talking in this kind of slang language
is what I'm trying to explain so he was
exaggerating and or it could be which is
a possibility that it was so long ago
that he did engage in those practices
and no longer does but what we know is
in this case what he is being a charge
for so what sorry what he's being held
for he doesn't be charged yet so what
he's been arrested for no one says that